of course switching off is easier said
than done I'm now joined in the studio
by Vanna I chose from the institute of
labor economics who's done research on
the subject of burnout and I'd like to
ask you first is burnout real has work
really become more stressful yeah the
given the data that we have at hand I
think it's an obvious development that
we're moving away from this that the
physical hazards of the old economy to
this mob psychosocial risks I'm
including burn out in the modern heavy
creative stressful world of work so this
is a real problem and there also is a
real debate about policies at a company
level to reduce the level of stress
there has digitalization made things
worse Oh or has it has it taken stress
away well in a way I think given the
data also that was crucial in the movie
um you can definitely see that the
intensity of information and the flow of
information has become faster and more
intense so this is one thing I'm on the
other hand down digitization is not
necessarily bad thing it also allows for
new ways of flexible responding to
certain demands i'ii be responding to
something about you not in the office
and also to interact with your colleague
to solve an urgent problem without going
through the office on the weekend for
example yeah that's an interesting point
I just imagine a top man I just sitting
at home with the dinner table the family
the kids are there and then the phone
buzzes and there's an email she's been
waiting for and she just quickly types
an answer and goes comes back to the
family twenty years ago she wouldn't be
at home with her family she'd be in the
office waiting for a fax so is that
progress or is it not I would say this
is a positive development because it
allows you to be combined family or
private activities with this business
requirements to a better extent term but
at the same time I think it's also uh
there's also the need for a mature and a
bit more more realistic a behavior
towards a digitization not potentially
contributing to further increase let's
say the information overload or do i
establish certain hide
principles are regarding emails and so
forth if you look at the figures it
looks like that we're working less in
Germany I think it's roughly three hours
less per week than 25 years ago are we
becoming too soft maybe when it comes to
hug I would not say so for full time
brokers I'm the routing time is
basically the same mom gave my scene
more part-time worker so well the same
why has it become more stressful well
people are expected to work more to have
a title deadline some productivity is
increasing also the need to be creative
and so subjectively this current create
certain are situations of stress but
only if the resources and in the social
environment that is available is not
favorable to such a development so
there's definitely an issue for formal
policies also for the working culture at
attleboro place that really makes a
difference our company's big companies
doing something and what are they doing
to reduce stress levels well i think
that the bigger companies are definitely
are in can dispose of better resources
to professionally address these issues
and they can establish a more formal
rules probably but the same goes also
with smaller companies and the basic
thing is the cake is in the eating us so
that means i'm in day-to-day practices
also are in terms of explicit or
implicit demands by for example managers
or your boss i think this really makes a
difference it's not so much about what's
written on paper or put somewhere on the
internet and that makes a difference and
i just from the institute of labor
economics thank you very much for come
to the studio today you're welcome